our leaf starts with a unitary event of
sperm fertilizing the ovum and that give
rise to the zygote and the zygote
divides divides and keep on dividing to
give rise to who we are but from
becoming the journey of becoming a cell
to a complete organism is complex and at
least it requires cells to divide and
give rise to more cell and this cell
division time for each individual is
different for example a drosophila
embryo divides within eight minute in
contrast a human stem cell of which give
rise to blood requires about 31 days to
divide so the cell cycle is divided into
several phases broadly they could be
classified into g1 phase synthesis phase
or S phase with the DNA replicates g2
phase or a preparatory phase for
segregation of the genetic material and
the mitotic phase were really the
genetic materials are segregated and two
individual cells are formed from one
cell but this process of cell division
cannot be uncontrolled if it goes
uncontrolled then uncontrolled cell
division would give rise to diseases
like cancer so the cell cycle has to be
controlled regulated and have better
there should be certain rules by which
the cells can divide and give rise to a
daughter cell so these sets of rule is
implemented by cell cycle checkpoints if
we look at the cell cycle
there are several checkpoints occurring
at several places during the lifetime of
the cell once a checkpoint that is in
the interface between g1 and s phase is
the DNA damage checkpoint so it it looks
for the damaged DNA if the DNA is
damaged it would
give the DNA give the genetic material a
time to repair by its autry auto
correction method but if it's not it
would decide whether the cell should
progress into the cell cycle or not now
another important check point is at S
phase because S phase is very important
for a cell's life at this phase of time
the cells replicate their DNA and
getting ready to segregate their DNA to
its daughter so the replication process
has to be very precise and very
stringently monitored and the DNA damage
checkpoint in S phase does this job even
after that a g2 phase when the
replication is done somebody need to
check that the replication that has
occurred has equally replicated the DNA
and and give rise to two identical
copies of the DNA so that is monitored
by the DNA damage checkpoint in the g2
phase
now once the replication is done all the
quality control is done now the DNA has
to be packaged informed of metaphase
chromosomes and they need to be equally
aligned in the microtubules such that
they can be segregated on the equal side
and give rise to two daughter cells and
that is monitored by the spindle
assembly checkpoint but have you ever
wondered that how checkpoints work so
just like a police checkpoint monitors
over the passing vehicles or any other
activities cell cycle checkpoint
monitors how cell divides when cell
divides and what is going inside the
cell when the cell is dividing so you
can understand there need to be a sensor
which can sense that whether the genetic
material is good damaged or need to be
repaired and that information need to be
conveyed to a signaling network that
could net that could instruct the other
downstream players to give rise to these
physiological responses
and all together the cell cycle
checkpoint machineries assure a quality
assurance now the top priority for the
cell is to equally divide its genetic
material to its daughter cells now that
process is monitored by DNA damage
sensors
it appears inside the cell there are
sensors which can understand whether
there is a damage in the DNA or not and
damage in the DNA would be understood by
these sensors as an error signal and
that error signal is quickly conveyed to
downstream signaling networks which
would try to reboot the system and give
the cell another chance to correct their
error now the cell the cell checkpoint
and the sensor always keep an eye on it
when the cell is replicating its DNA
making to DNA from one parental DNA at
this process several mistakes could
occur but the cell surveillance
mechanism always keep an eye on it such
that no mistake can occur at this
replication phase and another important
time when the replication is done and
the cell need to segregate its
chromosome the chromosomes need to be
aligned properly onto the spindles such
that equal segregation could happen and
proper tension could build up and that
is also monitored by g2m checkpoint that
is how we can understand that at several
phases of cell cycle there are
checkpoints which monitor several
aspects of cells important physiological
contents now in the metaphase stage if
the cells are not properly aligned onto
the microchip use on the spindles then
that's the error signal that is also
detected by sensors that we would be
learning about in consecutive videos and
that inner signal would tell the self to
stop and try to realign the chromosomes
properly onto the microtubules such that
the chromosomes can equally segregate to
the opposite poles and if it happens
then the cell pauses at metaphase and do
not proceed further to the anaphase now
have you ever wondered that what are the
molecular components of the cell cycle
checkpoints because cells has molecules
the molecules can interact in space and
time to monitor several cellular
processes but what are the molecular
components that give rise to this cell
cycle check on my scenery it turns out
one of the most important molecules that
give rise to the cell cycle checkpoint
mushie nuri is the cycling's and the cdk
complex the cyclin-cdk complex which
were together are very important for
cell cycle checkpoint now there are
cycling's which are proteins which
appear cyclically throughout the cells
cell cycle time point so as the graph
suggests that this magenta line occurs
in a periodic fashion so as the blue
lines so these proteins are synthesized
and degraded in a cyclic fashion that's
why they are known as cycling's and
there are several cycling's working at
several phases of the cell cycle which
are selectively appearing at that
particular cell cycle phase and getting
degraded one once that phase is over but
the cycle ends cannot work in isolation
they need their partner which are
cycling dependent kinase so the cyclin
and cyclin-dependent kinase interaction
give rise to a functional cyclin-cdk
complex and the cyclin-cdk complex works
like a kinase because the cdk are
basically serine threonine kinase they
can phosphorylate several downstream
effectors and give rise to and can
modulate several physiological processes
that would result in cellular division
and can prevent or induce cell
Division now throughout the cell cycle
from G 1 to s G 2 to M
there are several cycling and Siddha
cave complexes that work in combination
in g1 phase the prevalent cyclin-cdk
complexes are cyclin d and silica 4-6
whereas in s phases two type of
cyclin-cdk complex complex work
one is cyclin e cdk2 and cyclin a silica
two whereas the g2 2m transition point
is specially monitored by cycling B and
cdk1 now cycling and CDK could be also
modulated by other modulator like silica
activator kinase which give rise to
activate or e4 phosphorylation into the
cdk or the cdk-cyclin complex or there
are other cases where CDK inhibitors
inhibit the cdk and thereby inhibiting
the cyclin-cdk complex to function this
is how cycling's CDKs and also cyclin
CDK modulators together in a combination
monitors how the cell cycle progression
could occur and these constitutes of the
molecular aspects of the cell cycle
checkpoints in my next video
i would talk in way more details about
cell cycle checkpoint and exactly the
molecular details would be described in
my next video so stay tuned for my next
video and for then like share and
subscribe
[Music]